okay before we go we got to do human
friends be yeah what is a human friend
paid
it's a photo we always take that's like
the movie Human Centipede where they're
sewn together mouth to anus but it's
with friends so it's special
I get the middle oh why do you want the
middle this is it your bachelorette
weekend you've been dreaming about this
moment it's the first day of freshman
year we're gonna be swimming and dick
girl I just got a call from The busboy
so everyone's in I was kind of hoping
that we could make it an early night it
doesn't feel right
yeah I don't think so baby girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you got too much male or female doubt
ma'am I think email for her no no no do
I know you get the picture
you gonna do which one you're totally
[ __ ] take my picture there was this
guy in Australia who cooked his
girlfriend and ate her I can't cuz I am
vagin bye
[Music]
let's get steak be the best weekend of
our parking lot
I probably have HPV now whenever we all
have each baby I don't have HPV if
you've had sex after the 1991 then you
do have HPV oh then I have like a [ __ ]
ton of HPV clumps and clumps of it
[Music]
you